hey what's up party people welcome to
the honest trailer commentary for
spider-man no way home you've asked for
it you got it there's no way we weren't
going to talk about this movie come on
people it's the biggest movie
of the year of
all time top five
something crazy yeah it's the biggest
movie with three spider-men of all time
definitely that never been another three
spiderman movie that was bigger than
this one so we're gonna go a little
deeper into our thoughts uh about the
film then the honest trailer had a
chance to uh we'll show you some deleted
scenes we'll take some questions and
comments from viewers like you so keep
those coming in the chat and then we'll
tease you with next week's honest
trailer ooh that'll be a fun one too um
but we begin with spiderman uh all three
of them look it's impossible i think
it's impossible to just dislike this
movie i think you're lying if you just
like hated this or it's possible it's
well okay again all right if you enjoyed
it but i enjoyed a previous spider-man
film
it's do it's doing that to me this was
like
it was it was candy it was like it was
fluff but very enjoyable it reminded me
of um the phase i think in the early
2000s when people discovered like
mashups and it's like oh
you can play like dolly parton and like
nwa at the same time and it like sounds
good together like it was just taking
like here's things you already like
mushing them together uh so they sync up
and throwing it on screen i don't think
it was much deeper than that i think
they tried to do some interesting stuff
with like meta texturally with the idea
of reboots and bringing things back but
uh nothing that has been done so many
times this year that seems to be like
the one common theme of film is like
meta awareness of you you're being a
franchise and the actors within it
breaking the fourth wall but that's it
that's just my two cents uh danielle
what do you think
yeah i really liked it i agree like one
of the
and this isn't me like crapping on the
movie i really enjoyed it it was fun it
was everything i went into the movie for
but it does have that comfort of you
already know all these people you
already know all this you literally had
to do no thinking because it's all just
like slots exactly where it goes you
know so it's just like you get to be on
this fun roller coaster where you see
all of your friends again and you hear
about how they're doing and one of them
is really not doing well and you should
call them more and like it's but it's
like a really nice check-in so
you know it's i really enjoyed it it was
one of my favorite movies of last year
and
you know
it's one of those ones that's incredibly
rewatchable um i don't know that i'm
gonna i'm not i loved infinity war and
end game but i don't like re-watch those
all of the time but this one is one
where i feel like you can just like put
it on at any time and be super happy
yeah it does seem like like a
distillation of
the marvel project at large which is
like they can bank on your familiarity
with and the groundwork that they've
laid in other movies to just
throw something on screen and get an
emotional reaction out of you in this
next movie like they can just boom
there's doctor strange they don't have
to introduce him all he has to do is
like wink and twirl his goatee and
you're like yeah
they have no no setup necessary uh but
this that was this times a thousand uh
what do you think won
i mean i i think if we go back to like
ready player one which i feel like was
sort of the birth of the like reference
remember some guys trend that we're like
in the midst of now
uh where every movie is like remember
these guys and i'm like i do i do
remember those i do
it's still on comedy central yeah
like the
i think when ready player one came out
my my number one criticism was well this
is meaningless to me i like the iron
giant i like freddy i like beetlejuice
but these are they're appearing without
context they're just showing up and it's
like hi i'm freddie and it's like well
that who cares he's freddy and he's
interesting in the context of invading
the nightmares of teens and that's what
you want to see freddy do and i think i
want to see him uh hunt for easter eggs
as a gunter i can't wait to see
somebody want to see freddie gun we've
we've
progressed and like this movie's a lot
better than that and i think that
because they've figured out that it is
fun to remember some guys but that only
gets you a few minutes and then you do
need that context and this movie is full
of context it's these aren't just the
spider-man you've seen from other movies
they are those characters and they're
showing up with all the emotional
baggage and the personality and it's
deeper than just remember the tobey
maguire spider-man it really is playing
on
the action and the emotion and the beats
of the topic
yeah so on that level i thought they did
a really
impressive job of like taking a script
that's telling a new
story i mean
loosely but it's telling a new narrative
but that is laying in all of these beats
and this foundation that we know and
that we remember and it does like the
fact that they managed to get an
emotional payoff from andrew garfield
saving mj in this universe because we
remember that he failed to save his own
girlfriend in a preview so like that's
genuinely impressive like
when that happened in the movie the
first time i was seeing it the fans were
going crazy it was very it was nuts that
was the biggest of cheer and when we all
saw it was that but it's emotional like
the fact that it both elicits the
cheater and it's emotionally resonant
you can go back and re-watch the movie
and andrew garfield sells at the moment
really well
that's real emotional payoff like that's
impressive to me so i think that all my
other issues about the movie and i'm
sure we'll get into them the fact that
they were able to do that at all is like
a step forward
in this whole like
genre i guess yeah
yeah i think they did a great job uh
paying off emotions like you said and
balancing and uh reintroducing and
evolving characters uh and i think what
kind of slipped through the cracks was
like i feel like even marvel plots are
usually a little more buttoned up than
this and a little more thought out yeah
and look we're not cinemasins uh we
couldn't really dive into everything
wrong with uh peter's plan and doctor
strange i wish
but my god uh what a dumb plan all
around and so many like if you if you
scratch the surface just a tiny bit um
wow that doesn't make sense uh the whole
setup and
you know the the pipe that this movie
lays it's very faulty bad pipe um that
said uh we'll we'll get into it more as
we watch the honest trailer spider-man
uh no way hell let's do it
[Music]
you were like where the hell is it it
just came out whatever
second fiddle to iron man supporting
cast and second fiddle to iron man's
astrologer but this time tom holland
swings into uncharted territory playing
third fiddle to spider-man
spider-man no way home
so pause um briefly uh we can just give
our thoughts on like
this is probably the end of the solo tom
hall and spider-man movies it seems like
i mean of course they want more money
and you know whatever
i would have thought so
but the fact that it did
so incredibly well yeah uh
makes me think that probably not like
they'll probably figure out a way to do
to continue maybe even
i think we may be at the start of the
branching live action spider verses
where we're going to have multiple
spider men at any given time
in their own series but yeah i i like if
you if you hit me a year ago with this i
would have been like yeah i'd be like a
trilogy that'll probably wrap it up for
now now i i don't think so i think
they'll try to come back
yeah i mean and it did obviously like it
closed off this chapter of it because it
did very much feel like a series finale
right but
the fact that they left it so open to
okay well now
we're really seeing peter come into his
own in his role and become more of the
peter that you're used to from the
comics um
i think that it would be uh i mean they
could who knows what's gonna happen we
know that tom is like ready he's ready
to go he wants to do it while he still
has his knees so like
yeah
you know that's i i it would be remiss
for them not to at least do one
follow-up of like pete struggling
yeah which is wild that it took
five six seven appearances uh uh from
him to get to this point like even
though he's probably been in the most
films and uh has done the most you know
in universe i still feel like i know the
least and connect with the least with
with tom hall and spider-man just
because i think that they've always he
was introduced like
hosts you know taking on the uh the
mantle and that they've always paired
him up with someone bigger and stronger
to take on some sort of
massive universe uh shattering threat
and i just don't think we've gotten like
a
down-home spider-man movie out of him
yet i i do think that
you know they they there there may be a
method to their man there may be a
reason for that and i feel like he
and i know people disagree with me but
like i my
the tom holland peter parker take feels
like he's just kind of doing michael j
fox like we've always kind of get it's a
little bit one note it's a little bit we
get this beat he's a little nervous he
he's very smart and capable but he's
always feels like he's over extending
himself or whatever and it's just like i
feel like they may be doing that because
they just there isn't
he's not carrying these movies on his
own and they want to pair him with
another charisma machine so that they
can power through the movie i mean that
would be my that's my like instinct who
knows i don't have evidence for that
that's just my take on it but i do feel
like the fact that there were
these two movies where they keep you
know like giving him other people like
jake gyllenhaal and the second one or uh
downey jr in the first one and then in
this one he's got cumberbatch plus toby
mcguire plus it's like there must be a
reason that they've never been like
let's give tom holland a solo out well
there's that and i think there's also
like a business reason where they say
well this is like the character post
iron man to build you know the marvel
universe around we can't waste a
spider-man movie on just him you know
solving crimes well there's also the
sony marvel of it that's yummy and they
want to get the most bang for the buck
in terms of this team up like i get that
there's other i'm not trying to put this
entirely on tom's plate and uh you know
like i don't i don't think he i think
he's good and capable of he has other
gears uh in other films i'm trying to
think of what they are
in his in his original accent i've heard
him act uh
i've seen him in a few other things and
i've never
i've never been like you know who was
great in this
that that tom holland yeah
maybe i'm maybe i'm wrong i don't know
but like that would be my my inkling is
that these filmmakers are looking at him
and looking at what they're getting from
him and like yeah let's throw up any
cumberbatch in this one how dare you
he's 16 years old or 26 i have no idea
no
also i'm sorry have you never seen a
little thing called lipstick battle or a
lip sync battle have you noticed oh
there you go yeah i mean look if you
wanted to have him play rihanna in
something i'm open let's try it
well the time didn't really work
and time the the lip sync umbrella thing
has come up
within the first
the worst kept secret in nerdum is out
all the live-action spider-man are back
except for the two from the 70s
[Music]
messing up oscar nominated movies or
narrating the boss baby in a film that
pleases everyone from millennials who
look as old as toby did in spider-man 1
to younger revisionists who insist
everyone secretly loved the andrew
garfield movies
with so many in-jokes memes and
references you know
i'm something of a scientist myself
you'll swear you've been in a coma since
2014. you are amazing no i kind of
needed to hear that thank you huh
doesn't really sound too bad actually i
want to forget you're so soft poop i've
been a bad kitty
i genuinely forgot about the kevin
spacey dead guy cat
move like i had not thought about that
in years i know i was going to say like
what's one thing from between 2014 and
now that you wish let's say
cinematically
my jared
joker was my pitch for that that was my
country that's a pretty good one yeah i
i went down the nine lives uh remember
this hole what a pool
oh man so much to choose from though um
yeah uh i would love let's take a fan
question here because i thought this was
uh interesting is would you like to see
a continuation of the amazing spider-man
where he got bitter and stopped pulling
his punches like an andrew garfield like
let's go back to the garfield verse
which i want to comment on the
revisionist history going on here those
movies were not liked when they came out
um the first one a little bit and the
second one was just like okay it's done
we're dead let's move on let's do
something else
right like or am i or am i
misremembering what it was like to be no
i think the first one there it was like
it was a little divisive if i recall
because a lot of people including myself
were like andrew garfield's a good
choice and he's doing good like he's a
good peter parker i just don't really
love this take on the the world and the
effects or what whatever like the movie
uh the second one was the second one was
pretty universally like a lot of
comparisons to like batman and robin and
like they were obviously trying to do
[Music]
usefully like they were kind of trying
to like make it more of a comic book
kind of cartoonish sort of world and
play up that angle and i think audiences
were not into that at all
was the sony of it all were they uh they
realized oh crap all we have is
spider-man um we need to turn it into a
franchise that can launch multiple movie
properties at the same time and they
just stuffed it so furious trench coat
guy with the sinister six
yeah the hall of sinister six costumes
just all in a row waiting to be put on
by their different actors um yeah andrew
garfield i think always was likable ever
no one was pissed with his choice it was
kind of like a henry cavill situation
where it's like he didn't write the
movie he really deserved yes and
and so
the idea now that like oh let's go back
everybody loved it like
that that is definitely a revision
mistake although it does i get i get the
thinking that
obviously there's a split there's the
tom holland spider verse and then
there's the sony
spider verse where madame webb and venom
and dr michael morbius at your service
are all going to be hanging out and so
like
you know one of those could have tom
holland as spider-man and the other
could be the garfield verse like that
does make some kind of weird
sense to me
it's just we've had after 10 years of
remembering guys i'm just i've won over
like i would love that version of it
i would love garfield's you know dark
timeline spider-man to hang out with
morbius and venom i think that's that
just feels
fight right yeah
i know i feel like we've already got sad
pitiful batman in the uh um spider-verse
and the batman's oh yeah i'm not batman
sorry spider-man in the uh in the
spider-verse movies so i don't know that
we needed two of them but since they're
not like the same thing god i really
want i want the three spider-man to show
up in spider-verse i know i know but
even if it's just like for a second
we're just like oh wait are we not a
stay well that happened yeah i'm
assuming that that happened yeah
um but i didn't before they're shooting
now it didn't before
but yeah i i figured there would be a
scene where they would at least
pop in there right yeah no come on they
gotta and then just briefly um toby
maguire must be a real uh piece of work
off camera uh if he's uh the inspiration
for mr x and uh
do you see molly's game player x i guess
yeah yes yeah that's that's known like
that he definitely is
the inspiration at least like for
everybody watching topher grace i
believe is the actor in molly's game who
plays no um um
who is it oh michael sarah michael sarah
was like one of those guys uh that
character is based in real life that was
toby maguire yeah so go watch those
scenes then maybe it'll maybe your
cheers will be a little more damp the
next time he steps through a portal but
it happens all right let's keep
[Music]
revealed and peter's only solution is to
brainwash everyone so they forget all
the horrible things he's done tony would
be so proud
thrill as he teams up with a sorcerer
supreme to wave his hands around and say
multiverse until the sony films pop out
pulling in all the characters you loved
some of the characters you forgot about
and none of the characters sony would
like you to forget about in this
potentially cosmic thread that sounds
pause for a second great i mean i guess
this is our chance to talk about the
plot and the inciting incident and stuff
like that and how little sense it makes
um
so everyone who knows spider-man
like an infinite version an infinite
universe full of those people is like is
now colliding
with this one right
yeah so it's everyone who knows that
peter parker is peter parker from all of
the different multiverses yes so where
are like all the aunt mays but like in
different universes wouldn't different
people know that peter parker is
spider-man possibly so you can see in
some of the cracks there are like
outlines of people specific like there's
a there's a crave in the hunter there's
a scorpion like there are some ways you
can even see like who it's meant to be
yeah i think there's a writer when
they're somewhere yeah they're they're
like they're actually in shape some of
them are in villain shapes where they're
encouraging you to like
figure out who it is yeah like who's
that pokemon that's what i was saying
with that shot like that that's where
they're like they're actually pushing
through the multiverse like easter eggs
are trying violently to enter the moon
but the only ones who push through are
just these
villains from the iconic spider-man
films of the past there's no like
alternate aunt may alternate happy all
tony who lived in one universe uh you
know mjs a million mjs also there don't
seem to be like loki had other universes
where he was like
peter parker apparently always human
yeah where was spider-man's young boy
we're not getting that crazy live-action
spider pig that i need to see that
voiced by john mullaney
[Laughter]
all right keep playing a cosmic thread
that sounds like a job for doctor
strange but this time he's been replaced
with someone more like dr oz
i'm sorry sir
you should not be able to do that i've
been dangling over the grand canyon for
12. i know i know i know if he turns out
to be a scroll i'm going to be so pissed
last please with myself for calling it
wow spider-man is busy is it like it's
just got to be plot convenience like we
needed some mystical explanation for why
all this happened but we can't have
doctor strange just solve all of it or
is he a scroll like why is he so
incapable in this movie he has just
taken l after l after l
um my because that was
so my running theory of why that might
be my head canon is that now
uh so much of his power did come from
the time stone and from being sorcerer
supreme that he's been effectively
nerfed that makes sense okay that was
the way i justified it in my brain as
the movie was going on because if not i
was gonna think about it forever i i
really thought we were leading into a
third act twist where this was not the
real doctor straight yeah either a
skrull or the evil the bad doctor
strange from the what if or just another
variant or something
like that he was being held prisoner in
another dimension and this was like an
empire i really i genuinely into this
movie thought that was coming because it
doesn't really make everything from the
first moment we meet him
and
the you know sanctum is like there was a
blizzard and he's he's not the
sorcerer's supreme anymore and juan is
kind of goofing on him and like the
whole thing right from the start it's
like who's this guy he doesn't even it's
like benedict cumberbatch
a great actor
was doing like a different voice almost
i i felt like it was intense it's an
evolving thing yeah i felt like it was
intentional that it was like i'm gonna
play it a little different to imply that
this is not the real guy but then there
was no reveal it still could be coming i
guess because we have a whole doctor
strange movie on the horizon so that
could be like the first 10 minutes
introduces like ah you idiots
but even the even the sanctum like got
knocked down a peg they're like talking
about they don't have liability
insurance
you know like nothing's going on in the
basement i think the basement was like
one of my favorite parts um
because where else do you keep your dust
for man goatee
yeah you gotta you gotta comb it in like
literally non-stop goofing on he's like
the target for the entire movie which is
fine like i'm not protective of that
character but it's just like
it is it is a weird choice even zendaya
gets one on him oh yeah i literally
think every character gets a snap in on
him at least yeah and then he has this
like weird uh like rejoinder to to wong
where he says like we
something happened at a party where they
made one forget everything
oh yeah what happened to that magician's
party that's a that's a marvel one shot
we'll probably never see you would think
if you were dr strange like let like
what he says is like he's gonna finish
this spell and then everyone including
him
is going to forget
the context of what he just did like he
would finish his spell and then be like
wait what i just did a spell what did i
do i have no memory of why i'm here or
why i just did that spell if you're a
doctor strange you got to figure that
out you can't just like ah
back home guess it's no big deal like
you could have just ended the world bro
you're a powerful sorcerer yeah you
can't just be doing spells and then
forgetting about it and moving on with
the day let's go get a cupcake yeah
because i feel like the next couple of
days would be him being like what was
the spell i did like why did the next
happen why don't i remember
like a huge chunk of the last day or you
know like why am i missing things yeah
speaking of [ __ ] you got a scooby-doo
yeah you got to figure the case of the
missing spell like what like if you
can't just let that go man and is peter
still there when he gets out of the
spell or does he skeduce up out the
stairs before the spell is over also i
would like
to me this was even more so than the
plot like even more so like i could buy
the like dr strange does the spell and
the multiverse gets all screwy and all
these people start showing up all that
it felt a little like video gamey like
go take this gun and shoot all find the
guys coming through the portal with your
little map that i'm going to collect 10
villains yeah it's
very much like an assassin's creed like
i gotta mark my little map where all the
villains are but uh
i don't mind all of that what bugged me
was the end where it's like the the
solution is everybody forgets that they
remember that spider-man exists but they
forget who peter parker was but like i
don't get one does that mean all
evidence of him is gone from the world
like his high school transcripts
disappeared all of the text messages
from him on mj's phone that little
shrine in they built in his high school
where it's like
now it's just flash like magically does
all like every photograph everybody has
in their photo of them with him like
does all that disappear as well
because that was just full-on michael
jay boxing yeah
right because he just did the photograph
like start fading yeah the moment ned
looks at his phone he's gonna be like
who's this peter guy i've been texting
with every day for the last five years
of my life uh and then my my next
question is do let's say you're a person
that knew peter parker fairly well like
happy or nick or something
when you think back on memories from
your life where he was there
do you just have a blank or do you have
a false memory like does happy remember
the time he was hanging out with may and
peter was right there but he just
remembers a different scenario where
peter wasn't there or does he literally
not remember anything in his life where
he interacted with peter parker because
i think he's there but he just has
christopher plummer's face i think he's
just
cause that's like so you're giving the
entire city of new york brain damage
like just wiping out like big chunks of
everyone's life
yeah look
someone in the chat said bh pitt said
the inconsistencies were strange
probably because john watts is kind of a
bad director and look
i'm not agreeing
because he's a bad writer okay not that
direct
and then adam albert says are you guys
defending no way home means you're going
to be harsh on the batman get you a man
who can do both i i i prefer the batman
uh
that's not a rule yeah silly uh silly
adam silly uh that said uh let's move on
with the trailer we we've still got more
to set
while spider-man is busy fiddling with
two different magic boxes discovering
the scientific cure for evil and other
relatable teenage stuff like dating
zendaya or being too famous for college
you'll catch up with old pals like
flashlights
briefly about mit
were they
number one they all like the the movie
is premised on them just all assuming
they'd get into one of the most like
elite
institutions in america very smart
they're well yeah they go to like a stem
high school
okay super smart to get into there's a
lot of semi i'm just saying it was like
we're all gonna get into harvard
basically like okay sure now spider-man
um do you think for a second that
tony stark uh uh who
created that entire like wing of mit
would not put in a good word for tom
holland and like maybe like you know
what you should take this kid or happy
or stark industries or something like
that i mean to me it's like the bigger
issue is
this this entire the the entire world is
being really harsh on spider-man when
like dozens of other superheroes have
done even if you believe
like even if you fully take mysterio and
j-jo to jameson at their word and like
why would you
like we all know event like the hulk has
destroyed whole city blocks like the
scarlet witch blew up a skyscraper in
nigeria and then took an entire town
mentally hostage like if people are
forgiving all the other avengers i don't
see why they wouldn't be like yeah but
spiderman's our guy we loved him you
know like and we know that people
somehow know like the beat by beat what
happened in the fight against thanos
they'd be like well spider-man like you
saved half of all existence you can you
can
blow up a few bridges there are several
documentaries like we know that
yeah i feel like it's real a real
hypocritical approach like they're
they're okay with a whole lot of very
destructive superheroes but suddenly not
and it's like he's like a good-looking
white teenager they'd be fine like come
on there's no way
no he'd be a hero still yeah there's no
way come on all right anyways they're
letting him in
like what did you i was
uh surprised the shot uh did you guys
when you were watching the movie did the
green screen like everybody feeling like
they were in front of a fake background
did that really bother you because
that's what the internet is going crazy
about i didn't notice granted i
watched most recently on a laptop so it
didn't really pop out and i'm not like
scanning the background of the 10
seconds of flash that i got but that's a
shot where him on the street in new york
that
made it's a very brief shot in the movie
but when you look at it just as a freeze
frame it's obvious that he's not really
on a real game i mean now that you see
it uh yes it is noticeable and it's more
like why and i get like i did a little
digging and it's like oh for covered
reasons they couldn't have like a party
full and i believe they said tony
rebeluri friend of the show uh but had
had a he was like get a scheduling like
that must have been when they were doing
french dispatch or servant or something
and you couldn't physically do it at the
same time right but i do feel like it's
a bit of uh you know what has science
done because i think if they see that
they can do this then oh they like won't
even
bother like setting up real locations
for anything anymore they'll just save
us chloe yeah save us chloe's yeah
eternals is our last shot if we're using
real locations and it's gone yeah i mean
that was my day i didn't feel like it
was worse in this than most other marvel
movies like that like it's not a thing i
love but it's like if you're fine with
it in chiang chi i don't see why you
wouldn't also be fine with it it's it's
all of them they accept accept the terms
thank you uh adam halbert pop back in
the chat to say sorry trying to make you
pick dc or marvel i love the batman way
more than no way home well there you go
yeah you don't believe the hype you
don't have to choose um they're largely
similar in more ways than they're
different
we'll talk about it when the batman hits
digital there's there's some key
differences but i think you can totally
like both and that's not inconsistent
yeah okay let's keep watching in
somebody else he had to green screen
himself into a party the faculty of
midtown high who really deserved their
own disney plus series please mysterio
was right stop this we don't like this
oh sad happy i could have been more fun
hang out again wait what do you think
and ant-may who's ready to graduate from
being a female sex object to being a
female sex object killed off to motivate
the male hero oh don't feel too bad pete
everyone you love has to die no matter
what universe you're in my uncle ben was
killed it was myself pause i lost
anime's death seemed very did not seem
very smooth it seemed kind of forced in
and a little hackneyed especially her
saying the line and i'm not sure
how she died exactly because she seemed
fine and then she like died of regret
she steps up no no no no
there's pointy there's like knives on
the edge of uh green goblin's glider
yeah
and so she got you know she got she got
it's a very movie death where she's like
i'm fine i'm talking i'm bad like it was
i don't know that's not how people die
i've seen people die by glider that's
not how it looks
[Laughter]
anyways oh i think daniel froze unless
she's just very upset with me
i think she's frozen
she'll be back later
that's uh yeah how dare you make jokes
about aunt may's dad
all right we can we can move on from
that moment she'll be missed yeah i am
she was my mj
why are you crying this is supposed to
be inspirational
watch marvel pull off a sinister six
minus one like it was no big deal
featuring willem defoe's iconic green
goblin one of the best comic book movie
performances ever norman's on sabbatical
honey alfred molina's well-learned
victory lap as doc ock when he's not
being roasted by zoomers dr otto
octavius
wait no seriously what's your actual
name jamie foxx's electrode who improves
on his debut by changing every single
thing about it what happened to you did
you get a makeover sandmans
there and lizard who they keep in a
truck to hide the fact that he looked
better 10 years ago even reptile in the
new mortal kombat looked better even
reptile and the old mortal kombat looked
better but spidey won't give up on
curing all these bad boys of their
impure thoughts in fact he'll dose them
with hot liquid therapy then portal them
back to the lives they've already ruined
thanks spider-man norman osborne may
have lost his son company and reputation
but now he'll be able to feel crippling
regret over it
um
yeah what happens to them at the end of
this movie yeah my number one
thing that i didn't understand was the
peter parker spell at the end number two
would be how do you cure evil with like
a potion well i think black widow
already uh answered that it's uh it's uh
pheromones
it's it's just various smells and
perfumes that's mind control that's not
curing a person of being crazy what's
the difference i mean they're
controlling their minds into being uh
right
it's very implied that all of these
dudes were decent enough dudes until
they science to themselves and then the
science is what made them even
interesting so you can only de-evil
someone if science turned to me if they
were just evil
there's nothing you can do but well i
guess themselves but then doesn't this
lead to the moral question of like if
you science yourself into being evil
doesn't that mean you were already evil
would would a good person science
themselves into being evil that's our
conundrum on the show today let us know
in the comments below what you think
well if that that works except for
sandman who's just like a guy who fell
into a pit not even like i just work
here
i guess that carried over yeah he was
just kind of a
a nice dope like he no he was a thief
what marco was a thief but like for his
daughter right or no yeah no i believe
you're right i believe you could justify
his crimes because he was trying to take
care of his daughter and it's not his
fault that uncle ben died i guess he was
working as a mechanic for a small
nantucket airline oh no that's wings i'm
sorry that's
his previous work in the sitcom
yeah uh and then the uh the lizard like
didn't he get i'm also confused like
when they get pulled out of their own
reality because you know right green
goblin it's like right before he dies
and the lizard was like lizard gets
cured doesn't he and strange wanted to
just send them back
to like the moment before they get
killed and let those universes
spider-man kill them and then aunt may
and and spider-man's like alternate plan
is
cure them of being evil but i don't
figure i don't understand but are they
still sending them back to the moment
where they died or they sending them
back earlier so they have a chance to be
like hey i'm not evil anymore spider-man
don't kill yeah but lizard in particular
i think if i recall like an amazing
spider-man he was a lizard for like
you know a couple hours of his life for
the climax of that movie and then he
transformed back into a person and they
chose those two hours to pull him just
the just the worst most lizardy two
hours of his life the end of his movie
i don't remember yeah i mean he did
peter 3 does say i cured him before i
can do it again oh you're right yeah say
that you're right yeah right so it's
just there's no problem right here
before so basically no problem oh no
problem wow there you go no dinosaurism
no problem we should knock this out
right away
oh silly i mean look they're coming
probably just be working at like a
hospital if he knows the cure for
everything in like an hour like well
that's that's the tony stark question
right it's like medical
yeah what are you doing here making
making bombs and gun suits uh unless you
want to okay keep going here when you
see it in theaters
[Applause]
yeah when john watts is saying longer
it looks like she's about to like start
doing double dutch and she's just
getting yeah and ready for like her turn
to jump in
on her most tragic euphoria day
it's funny like how
you know between euphoria and dune and
like her her real life and stuff like
that like i now
i mean i'm i'm more impressed with this
performance because like she's really
but it's also appropriation because
she's doing awkward voice and we know
she's not awkward
she's she's definitely
taking on like uh it's a real
transformation now that we know zendaya
is like the most glamorous person
she's she's doing the bit like of the
main trio in these she's like definitely
the best actor right i think we all i
think we all agree on that's pretty i
think himself yeah yeah i think yeah too
bad
i don't know this was my theory about
may that i was gonna say before i got
cut off
my thought is that why all of this stuff
is happening in this movie is because
that's how long they have them for and
they don't know if they want to pay the
money to bring them back next
thing i think you're right i think this
was like a do we have anything we know
we want marissa to may for
moving forward or could we
you know could we wrap
wrap that up because that's that's a
paycheck yeah do we want to pay zendaya
has an emmy now money
yeah you kind of have to i feel like the
main trio you don't know gwen stacey
someone else yeah whoever's yeah that's
true well sydney sweeney gwen stacy
right they said sidney sweeney is in
madame webb and everything oh really
okay well there you go everybody's like
uh oh glenn stacy alert yeah
yeah i mean marvel is so good at making
uh these ruthless mercenary financial
decisions seem like they were made out
of love and respect and emotional payoff
um that's what they're good for all
right keep going
because those moments are just awkward
to watch by yourself at home
okay
you just grab my breath here
okay
one more beat
it's a lackadaisical
still an amazing two and a half hour
brain vacation that's the cinematic
equivalent of all your exes coming
together to reminisce on all the good
times you had i love you guys and not
the time they made you well you know
watch amazing spider-man 2.
starring
peter parker picked a pack of partners
whip whip boom
the spider house rules zen and the art
of multiversal maintenance ant-man the
sorcerer's apprentice the assistant to
the regional sorcerer if i were a fixed
man
the green golem
project power
i don't like sand
welcome back connors alex jones jameson
netflix and billable hours and say the
line say it with great power there must
also come great responsibility yay
the adventures of pete and pete and pete
don't let mit be dumb like me mit is
dumb well you're the vice chancellor and
you can't figure out a child-proof lock
so
maybe door's locked
yeah it's not a cop car no it's just a
car
also
of course he wasn't saying
the institution mit is dumb i don't
think she would be offended on behalf of
the school he said
don't make a mistake it's a pretty
obvious colloquial i don't know maybe
she thinks mysterio was right oh maybe
that's like a black conspiracy
[Laughter]
along with the illuminati here have a
bean pie mysterio was right
yeah there's a um
that was a fun little moment one that uh
didn't make it in even to the delayed
scenes was uh i noticed that peter
parker for all of his secrecy about
being spider-man uh has a taped-up piece
of paper in his apartment that says iron
spider charging don't
unplug and like a million wires going to
his closet she's like you know uh mark
webb being like this is a cute moment
not really thinking the whole thing
through
um okay so i think we have some deleted
scenes for this one that we should play
was that right cause webb did webb did
the amazing
oh uh yeah you know these are the watts
these are the watts versus webb excuse
me watch versus what yeah
central parker it's my stick in the box
garfield and friends
okay doomer
mr x
the parker posse
toby one kenobi
danced with this role
i won't remember you
will you still creep on me
soak hogan
the guy in the hair
tony spark the goat e
the power of the dock army of dorkness
awkward finding gobby
willem the foe
the quick brown fox jumps over the lazy
dust john watts django
church is chicken the lizard of was
infowabs you know you think you'd have
been all over an actual lizard person
sighting
public defender
street shark
a tingle in time along came a few
spiders
magic what's happening
spider-man three-peat
is there a rule somewhere that says tom
hardy and tom holland can share a movie
together but never be on screen at the
same time uh mom's getting sausages oh
yeah and guess what she's wearing the
shirt as well dad it is so embarrassing
new school new town i can spider-man
there i mean they have crime in boston
right yes you know somewhere in the
multiverse lives a boston spider-man
protecting the duncan's over in
dorchester wearing a pat's jersey
i would watch that
yeah i was confused there's there's one
alt that we definitely made but got cut
that was about doctor strange uh you
know getting
whopped all around his uh own movie and
then being like just in time for his own
sequel
which is weird because this is like the
after after credits thing was just yeah
they liked it
i also uh while i'm reminded while we
saw the clip there uh not only like
obviously daredevil showing off his
superpower by catching the brick as it
comes through the window before it hits
peter whoever threw that brick
potentially also a super that the
i think it's homelander out there trying
to kill spiderman yeah
yeah um good stuff good stuff uh lucky
that uh matt murdock was there at that
moment
so we've got some really good uh fan
questions rolling in um
uh let's start with this simon smith
theories on why aunt may dumped happy
well she says it was like just a fling
right but also happy for
has a really pathetic life given that
he's probably like a huge corporate
executive for like i don't know the
equivalent of raytheon or something in
this in this universe like he should be
living a a more glamorous life than he
does it's very sad in his little
bachelor apartment yeah his post i feel
like uh we don't get a good sense of
like is pepper
like looking out for him or is she like
distracted and doing her own thing and
like he seems very lonely and adrift
post tony yeah very much um so yeah i
think aunt may is just she's like a
rebound from tony
i mean yeah i feel like yeah she's got
you know she's like she's single and
living in the big city she's got a lot
of options she doesn't want to be tied
down to this guy forever apparently
there's a there's a deleted scene but i
haven't seen it yet that kind of
addresses more why they broke up
um okay
check that out uh bh pit rights why
didn't they give all the spider-man more
distinct costumes and this is something
that like i've noticed uh when it's like
people talk about the video games and
just when they release a new spider suit
is i have like spiderman face blindness
where like all the costumes look very
very similar to me so i agree it is very
tough to make them out especially when
they're all in motion um and that would
have been a funny moment if they're like
peter one peter two peter three or
whatever and they like put numbers on
their chest
like they're running a 5k i feel like
the answer is every new spider-man
franchise that comes out they don't want
to change the costume into extreme away
because that's the consistency from from
see from series to series we're changing
the actors to the characters changing
the world but like spider-man is still
spider-man
uh and then for this movie they wanted
to mimic the looks from their own movie
so you're kind of locked into what was
in the movie you can't just have tobey
maguire in a brand new spider suit
because it's supposed to feel like he's
from the rainy movies yeah
aditya agarwal asked if he could replace
one peter from no way home with japanese
spider-man takuya uh which would you
choose
tom holland
i mean i
told you probably like i liked her
probably contributing the least if i was
going to pick one guy to be from planet
spider
but i mean if if he came through that
portal i would i would [ __ ] my pants i
would it would be the best day of my
life i do feel like leah pardon maybe
will be in the background of uh the
spider verse
yeah i feel like that the work came into
spider-verse yeah probably more likely
uh bruins fan 1144 uh tom holland wants
mark wahlberg in the mcu who should he
play um boston
spider-man the multiverse he plays best
in spider-man all right i'm a spider-man
like you say hi to me
friendly neighborhood spider-man
oh yeah yeah velvety's up on the north
end let's go
um
okay okay let's go uh james bunt when
are we going to get miles morales and
spider gwen in live action
uh it sounds like you're saying there's
a gwen stacey and madame well we don't
know i i don't want to put that out
there in the world like it's confirmed
yeah sydney sweeney the actress is going
to be in the madame webb movie with
dakota johnson
that's all we know for sure a lot of
people are guessing that they're going
to use that as an opportunity to
introduce gwen stacy to the sony
spider-verse yeah i would
it makes sense to me
but i don't know if that's true that's
just the root
makes sense um only a matter of time
they will be they'll get there they'll
get there
uh i love this one matteon blenski yes
uh which 2021 india art house film
moments deserve wooing like in no way
home
uh we you can broaden it to any year but
like what's a what's an indie
indie film or non-superhero film moment
that you think the crowd should go go
crazy for
oh
um
uh definitely 40 minutes in to drive my
car when the opening credits start and
he gets it
like he gets in and he starts the car
and he starts driving and then the
opening credits play that's a big
applause break moment come on the ground
goes wild he's driving the car
yeah i would definitely say uh in zola
it's the moment when um lizzo runs out
oh yes
i feel like there's gotta be at least
one more good one i think uh
maybe lost the final scene of lost
daughter when she pulls out an orange
and starts peeling an orange yeah
or maybe
oh any appearance by the babadook
the papa dude
anytime that little top hat pops up yes
yes
crowd goes wild i mean for spencer you
could cheer anytime one of your favorite
or least favorite royals you know steps
through a a sitting room door every
every time
every time somebody comes in it rustly
closes the curtains yeah
spencer
uh and then um pig when he when you
realize at the end when he's like he's
gonna cook like oh he's gonna cook a
meal and he's like gathering the
ingredients he finally gets a bite of
his salted baguette yeah
a lot of cheer worthy moments um
ryan says when he comes out of the goo
in dune that's not a it's not an indie
film come on that's it yeah uh and jim
one will end with this uh if you could
have added one more surprise appearance
into the movie what would it have been
um well i'm going to tie this back to
somebody else
somebody else yeah uh other than that
spiderman um somebody else suggested
this uh i don't want to not give them
credit but it's somewhere oh yeah bruins
fan again uh toe for grace should have
shown up only for tom hardy to appear
and bite his head off that would have
been a great venom
eating his past moment do you guys
remember that early aughts mtv
spider-man cartoon it was yes early
early days patrick harris
computer animation tv so now going back
like at the time i watched it i was like
this looks amazing this is so cool they
could do this for tv now now it looks
like when you go back like toy story
what like oh my god we've been created
yeah yeah like right it's like reboot uh
so it would be really funny to see that
level of animation neil patrick harris
spider-man just show up in there
yeah yeah it's like basically like like
original lara croft from tomb raider
just alongside live-action spiders yeah
oh
pyramid boobs um i would definitely i
mean i've said it before i will continue
to say i will continue banging this drum
i want the one from the spider-man
musical
yes
turn off the dark yeah
oh man um we'll have to do that for the
honest trailer for that for the next
spider-man movie because we've run out
of spider-man movies so we'll have to do
turn off the dark somehow
um all right i also love that the uh the
uh unbreakable kimmy schmidt parody of
turn off the dark is called too many
spiderman which i did
works perfectly as a title for this film
and it's a number two too many spiderman
because it's the follow-up to turn off
the dark dang oh man i gotta watch kimmy
schmidt uh
that's oh man that episode it's titus
her roommate is auditioning to be in too
many spiderman nice setup event
well that's all the spider-man for now
but he'll be back in one form or another
uh pretty soon i'm sure if this movie is
any indication so we'll be back as well
uh next week for another comic book uh
themed thing that will be uh pretty uh
pretty fiery i think it'll be it'll be
spicy it'll be hot um and that's your
clue for next week uh tune in then for
another australian commentary we'll see
you later bye
[Music]
you